في شركه تكنولوجيا في الهند منعت موظفيها
من الخروج دون اذن بطريقه ما يمكن انه
تتخيلوها ولا يمكن حتى ان تخطر على بال
احد خلونا نشوف مع بعض
الفيديو اللي شفته لعنصر امن في شركه
هنديه يعني لتكنولوجيا المعلومات وهو كان
بيستخدم سلاسل واسلاك واكفل كبيره علشان
يمنع الموظفين من انهم يخرجوا من الشركه
من دون موافقه المدير وقال انه المدير هو
اللي قال له يعمل كده يعني طريقه صراحه
جديده واكيد ما احد سبقه يعني على هذه
الطريقه ويعني في تنفيذها يعني طيب المهم
انه بعد ما انتشر الفيديو طبعا على
المنصات بشكل كبير بدات ردات الفعل اللي
اتهمت الشركه باستغلال الموظفين واهانتهم
والشركه اضطرت انها تنشر بيان قالت في انه
اجراء مؤسف وانه تم تصحيحه فورا وانه
الموظف اللي عمل هذا التصرف اعترف بخطئه
واعتذر